hello everyone here on freecodecamp
today and welcome to this course on
nosql
my name is annie cooper and i'm a
software developer and course creator on
youtube as well as your instructor for
this video
in this video course i will be
demystifying what nosql is clarifying
the difference between sql and nosql as
well as going into a deep dive of the
four main types of nosql databases with
each deep dive we will be approaching
each learning as an explanation example
and exercise so the three is in order to
fully grasp the topic we are discussing
after that we will go straight into
using what we have learned with two real
life use cases by use cases i mean we
will be getting data into real life
projects using a document api and the
graphql api to communicate with our
newly made databases
and finally i will be wrapping up with
where to go next
don't worry if none of this makes sense
to you now this is what the tutorial is
for as always if you like what we are
doing here at freecodecount please do
give that subscribe button a click as it
would really help us on our mission to
provide a broad spectrum of learning
materials right here free to access for
you
now let's get to it
so the first thing you need to know is
that nosql is an approach to database
management it is considered to be super
flexible as it allows for a variety of
data models such as key value document
white column or tabular and graph
formats
these are the four we'll be looking at
today as well as a new emerging trend of
multi-modal databases
so we have already mentioned that no sql
databases are casually considered to be
flexible but officially the defining
characteristics of nosql databases are
considered to be that they are
non-relational distributed and scalable
distributed refers to running on
clusters of machines globally
distributed to support apps at a
different geographical locations
and scalable means that nosql databases
are able to store and query large-scale
data as well as support high transaction
throughput scaling horizontally
in addition to this they also partition
tolerant meaning that they are able to
work in the presence of network
partitioning
and they are also highly available
meaning that they are able to serve
requests even when some machines go down
they can do this as they have data
replication built in
and lastly what does non-relational
entail to understand this fully we need
to look at relational databases first
the relational data model and sql were
designed for databases that work on
single machines and scale vertically we
will go into this in a bit more detail
later on
in fact everything we just mentioned is
in contrast to what relational databases
are all about which is atomicity
consistency isolation durability or acid
for short i am bringing up relational
databases as to understand where no sql
came from we have to look at them as
well as sql
sql stands for structured query language
it is used for relational databases by
relational i mean it's a collection of
tables with rows and columns that stores
a specific set of structured data
no sql is used for non-relational and
relational databases okay so when you
think sql think are the structure query
language for database management on
relational databases and think rigid and
when you think no sql well let's have a
look at the word itself nosql
you might think okay so it's the more
flexible way to access data so not using
sql the structured query language simple
right well you would actually be wrong
because of the usefulness of sql many
nosql databases added support for sql
leading to an understanding among
developers that no sql actually means
not only sql so you can use the
structured query language or you cannot
use the structured query language it is
up to you
so once again to recap sql is a
structured query language and no sql is
an approach to database management got
it
good
in the book nosql distilled a brief
guide to the emerging world of polygon
persistence the writer explains two main
reasons for using a nosql database the
first is application development
productivity when developing an app
there is a significant amount of time
before starting anything really that is
spent on organizing data
by organizing i mean mapping data
between in-memory data structures and a
relational database so in other words a
type of database that supports sql as we
just mentioned as a non-relational
database manager approach nosql can
provide a data model that better fits
the application's need and in turn makes
our life easier in the long run as the
data model is more suited to the
application it makes the debugging and
writing code easier as well as allows
for easy evolution
the second reason is large-scale data
as we know organizations today love to
capture as much data as possible to
improve their offerings as well as other
things however capturing large amounts
of data and processing it quickly is
expensive in terms of an operation so
whilst it is possible to do so with
relational databases it is usually more
economic to run large data and processes
on lots and lots of little cheaper
machines or clusters that no sql
databases are designed to explicitly run
on rather than one large one as is
typical for relational databases we will
go into this in more detail in the next
section
so in conclusion no sql is a database
management approach the characteristics
we can expect from a nosql database are
that it is a non-relational database as
opposed to a relational one a
distributed database that is designed to
manage large-scale data while
maintaining high performance scalability
throughput and availability
now when people look at nosql and sql
they might be tempted to compare the two
but by now we know that we can't do this
why again this is because once again
nosql is a database management approach
and sql is a query language so two
completely different things
it might be better going forward to
start referring to nosql databases as
non-relational databases so let's go
ahead and switch that so we can start
comparing them to relational databases
from now on
as we mentioned relational databases use
the structured query language a language
that became prominent in the late 1970s
and nosql means not only structured
query language which allows you to use
the language or not use it to get data
no sql appearance on the scene is noted
as somewhere around the 2000s
with sql the data is modeled as tables
with fixed columns and res
and with no sql databases the data is
not only modeled as tables with fixed
rows and columns instead it can be
modeled as json documents graphs with
nodes and edges key value pairs or with
y column or tabular databases where
columns can be dynamic from row to row
within a table instead of fixed
with a nosql database the schema is
flexible this means there doesn't have
to be any real fixed structure to the
data it can be stored in a flexible
schema way
this approach can make development
easier due to the high level of
flexibility
with a relational database the schema is
fixed they will have rigid data types so
if you want to put a boolean into a
column that has been defined to only
take integers the attempt will get
rejected think of it as a super strict
approach
and whilst this strictness can be good
it also comes with its downfalls and can
be very time consuming when trying to
implement changes
and finally let's look at scalability
no sql usually scales out
this is also known as horizontal scaling
this involves adding more and more
machines to the resource pool rather
than adding resources by scaling
vertically like relational databases do
so while no sql scales out sql scales up
by adding more resources i mean it adds
things like a more powerful cpu and ram
to handle workload and improve
performance rather than adding more
machines such as servers
as mentioned there are four main types
of nosql database systems each using a
different data model once again they are
the key value document y column or
tabular and graph database types
as mentioned we will be also taking a
quick look at the emerging trend of the
multi-model type at the end too
we will be going through each type in an
explanation example exercise format okay
so once again the three is now the first
thing you need to know is that databases
have multiple layers the first layer is
an interface or in other words a visual
platform where you can visit and
interact with data which is where you
find the format the language and the
transport in this course the interface
we are going to use is called datasacks
astro database management system this is
where we will be creating all of our
database types for the example and
exercise parts
datasax astrodb is an autoscaling
database as a service built on apache
cassandra designed to simplify
cloud-native application development
because it is built on apache cassandra
you will see us using the cassandra
query language or cql a few times in
this course
cql offers a model close to sql in the
sense that data is put in tables
containing rows and columns i will be
pointing this out to you when we use it
these languages are how we interact with
the data in our database
the next layer is an execution layer
this is where we pass the incoming
queries coming from our interface it is
also used as an analyzer and a
dispatcher
and finally we have the storage layer in
which the indexing of data happens
the reason i am using datasets astra is
that it will allow us to create all four
types of database types for this
tutorial so i won't have to sign up to
separate database management systems for
each section however you don't have to
there are literally dozens and dozens to
choose from so please feel free to take
your pick
we can group these database management
systems into families according to the
cap theorem according to the cap theorem
a nosql database cannot achieve
consistency availability and partition
tolerance it must sacrifice one of the
three for example mongodb and kafka
chose to focus on cp and the database
management system we are going to be
using datasex astra is built in apache
cassandra which chose to focus on ap
so to recap what we are doing here is
using datasax astra which is an
interface essentially that will allow us
to work with our nosql database which is
in this case apache cassandra to be
exact apache cassandra is an open source
nosql distributed database the language
we will use to communicate with our
database is cassandra query language or
cql for short which as mentioned is very
similar to sql
most nosql databases have their own
query language but not
once you are on the sacs astra platform
we're going to create a database so i'm
just going to head over and click this
button right here and that will take me
to the page in which i'm going to create
our first database
under database name i'm going to call it
fcc underscore tutorial i would
recommend calling your database exactly
the same in order to avoid any issues
further on for this tutorial of course
once you have the knowledge that you've
gained after this tutorial you will be
able to name your databases anything you
wish this is just a suggestion however
now under key space name because the
first example we're going to look at is
tables i'm going to call the key space
tabula
once again i would recommend that you
call your key space name the same thing
so that you don't run into any issues
further on
okay and next we can provide a region we
can choose amazon web service or
microsoft azure or google cloud i'm just
going to stick with this one and i'm
just going to select europe as i'm
currently in europe and i'm going to
create a database
and there we go we have created our
first database it has a database id the
status is currently pending so we're
going to have to wait for that to turn
active before we can go ahead and use
the database
and there we go we're active as you can
see here the status has turned to active
in green great now that we have set up
our database management system let's
start getting to some examples
okay great now let's look at the first
database type which is a tabular
database type also known as a column
database type or a wide column database
type what you need to know is that
tables are relational and come with a
schema we are going to be making a table
called books in this next section and
defining what kind of rows the table can
take and what kind of types the rows are
made of
for example i'm going to have a table
called books and in it i'm going to say
that we can only have a row that has a
book id an author a title a year of
release the categories the books belongs
to and a time stamp for when it was
added i'm also going to say that the
book id needs to be a uuid or a
universally unique identifier the author
field needs to be some text and the
title needs to be some text too the year
needs to be an integer and the
categories need to be a set of texts and
the time sum needs to be a type of
timestamp format and only that okay so
what i have done here is essentially
define a schema
the next thing that is important to know
is that we are going to be saving this
row based on a key
this is important as this is how we are
going to be retrieving our data with
queries later on okay so for example if
my uuid for this row looks like this and
i can save it the only way i can find it
is by searching for this key and the
whole data row will be returned
this key is also what is known as a
partition key because our nosql database
is a distributed database it means our
data can be stored on loads and loads of
different nodes so if two rows have the
same partition key they will be stored
together on one node and when we query
for that key they will both return
got it
good
now let's use this in practice with an
example in which we are going to be
storing books in a tabular database
so now that we have created the database
and is active to use let's go ahead and
create our first table
to do this i'm just going to double
click on the database itself it should
take you to this page in which you will
see the key spaces associated with this
database
at the moment there is one as we only
created one key space called tabula
great
so now i'm going to do this part using
the cql console
so as we know tabular databases organize
data in rows and columns okay so that's
what we're going to be doing we're going
to be building a table with rows and
columns to store some data using cql or
cassandra query language
the first thing i'm going to do is use a
command in order to get our key space
so to do this i'm going to enter the
following command it is called describe
key spaces and if i hit that you will
see all the key spaces associated with
my database you will also see that
tabula is right here
just to make sure we are all on the same
page a key space is simply a word for a
logical grouping of tables
so now that we can see our tabular key
space let's actually get to using it i
can use it using the following command
use tabular and just hit enter don't
forget to put these semicolons at the
end
okay so now you will see that i'm
actually in the tabular key space i'm
inside the key space i now want to
create a table
inside the key space and i'm going to
use the following cql command to do so
i'm going to write create table if not
exists okay so that is something you're
going to need to create a table in your
key space and i'm going to call the
table
books
now i'm going to actually define what
goes into my table as well i'm going to
define what it is i want to put into my
table and what type it is
okay
so for example if i choose to put in a
book id and then also going to state
that this is a unique identifier okay so
from now on i can only use universally
unique identifiers or uuid as the book
id
for those of you who don't know what a
uuid is it is a
128-bit label used for information in
computer systems i will show you the
structure of it as well as what it looks
like when we get to using it later on
next i'm also going to say that my table
of books is going to have an author and
the author so whatever value i have as
the author is going to be text okay so a
string in other words
we're also going to have a title which
is going to be text
a year which is going to be an integer
okay so a full number we're going to
have categories which is a set of texts
okay so once again i will show you what
that looks like we're going to have
multiple categories or in other words
it's going to be a set of texts and i'm
also going to have added which is going
to be a timestamp i have defined added
to be a time stamp so timesam is also a
type in cqr
and finally we're going to have a
primary key
a primary key in basic terms is how
we're going to search for a book in our
table okay so imagine our table has
hundreds and hundreds of books we can
filter through the table we can search
through the table by the book id thanks
to this primary key right here
the book id that i've passed through
into the primary key is also the
partition key that we discussed earlier
in the introduction okay so i'm putting
in a partition key
into the primary key
great i'm just going to close that off
and don't forget the semicolon and press
enter
and there we go we have now created our
very first super simple table using cql
just to make sure that has worked i'm
just going to use the command describe
key space tabular so this time i'm
picking out the precise key space
and putting the semicolon and then just
hitting enter
and there we go
we can see that our table has been
created okay with the book id added
author categories set and yeah
wonderful
so now that we have finished our table
we have created our table let's actually
get it putting things into our table to
do this i'm going to use the command
insert into so i'm going to use insert
into that is a command that we're going
to use to insert data into our books
table so i'm just going to write the
word books
and then once again i'm just going to
put in a book id an author a title
a year
the categories that it belongs to
and added
and just click enter
the next i'm going to do is actually add
the values so we didn't actually finish
off this command there's no semicolon so
we did not finish of this command we're
just making a new line so it's more
readable and i'm just going to put some
values
into our books
so i'm just going to open up the
parenthesis and i'm actually going to
create a unique identifier so this is a
function i'm going to call this so that
it creates a universally unique
identifier for me
the next thing i'm going to do is write
a string of bobby brown as we defined
author as text so this needs to be text
it needs to be a string
and then we're also going to give it a
title which is also text it is a string
so i'm going to put dealing with tables
the next is year which we defined as an
integer so i'm just going to put 1999
and then categories which is a set of
texts so to do this i'm just going to
open up some curly braces this time and
i'm going to put the string of
programming and this string of computers
this is because i define categories as a
set of text so i can only put text into
this set
okay
and finally once again i'm going to call
a function the function is called to
timestamp and i'm going to open up my
parentheses and i'm just going to put in
another function it's called now i'm
gonna call it
this will essentially create a timestamp
with this very second okay so timestamp
of this very second that i'm gonna put
into my table
and i'm just gonna close all this off
and finish it off with some semicolons
because i'm done with this command now
and just click enter
wonderful
so now let's see if that has worked
i'm going to use the command select
all so this little asterisk means all
from our table called books so we have
chosen to call the table books so that's
why i'm using the word books here and
then let's get our semicolon and just
click enter
and
what the [ __ ]
here is our table we have created a
table we've put some data into our table
let's have a look here you will see the
uuid has been generated this is the
structure of universal unique identifier
that looks wonderful
next we've got added okay so this is the
function that i wrote two times up now
if i use the function today's timestamp
down to the second has been used to
populate this cell right there
and next we have the author of bobby
brown the categories and the title
dealing with tables
as well as the year which is an integer
great so we've created one row
in our table let's get to adding another
row into our table
so to do this once again i'm just going
to use the command insert into again i'm
going to pick out the table that i
created earlier which i chose to call
books
and i'm going to say that into this row
i'm going to put in a book id an author
a title a year
categories and added
okay and then the values that i want for
these cells are going to be once again
i'm going to use the uuid function to
create a universally unique identifier
for me i'm also going to put a string of
let's put andrea agnes as the author for
the title i'm just going to put the moon
as the title of my book and for the year
i'm going to put 2001 as an integer so
not a string the categories i'm going to
put space and non-fiction
non-fiction like so
and then added once again i'm going to
use the two time stamp and pass through
now and call it
okay
so there we have it
once again i'm just going to close that
off and then use a semicolon to finish
this command and hit enter
wonderful
so now if we look at everything in our
books table so i'm just going to use the
command to select all books
oops we didn't use this semicolon select
all books
select or from books apologies select
all from books is the command we need
wonderful we can see now that two rows
exists on our table that we created
great
this is looking
really good
as you can see a new unique identifier
has been generated a new timestamp the
author name some categories a title and
the year as an integer
great
now what if i just want to select one
thing from our table
well as we mentioned we know that we can
use a primary key to the book id to do
this so let's go ahead and try do that
i'm going to use the command select all
so once again select and then we use a
little star or asterisk from books and
i'm just going to hit enter so i'm not
going to close off this command yet and
i'm going to use the command where
and then use book id equals so i've
chosen book id from my cells i've called
it book id and i'm just going to select
a unique identifier let's select this
one
so what do we expect to return if we run
this command
great that is correct we are now getting
one item from our table this is because
we chose to select an item by its unique
identifier okay
so there we go we have now successfully
picked out one item from our table using
the book id or in other words the
primary key
so we have now seen how we can pick out
one item from a table however how can we
filter out multiple items from a table
well to do this we're going to work with
partitions
so
let's make a new table for this
i'm just going to refresh my page
you can actually also use the clear
command instead of refreshing the page
if you want to clear all of this it's up
to you
so once again this is going to be some
great repetition for you some great
muscle memory practice
first off let's actually get to listing
out all the key spaces using the
describe key space command
there we go we can see the key space
that we want the tabular key space i'm
going to use the command use tabular in
order to pick out the key space that we
want
next let's actually get to creating a
table in the tabular key space okay so
we have one table already called books
i'm going to create another table this
time so the command you need for this is
create table if not exists and then
we're going to choose to call our table
restaurant by country
okay so i've chosen to call my table
this you can choose to call your table
whatever you wish
and now in my table well i'm going to
decide that i want to have the following
columns i'm going to have the country
which i'm going to define as text
next we're going to have cuisine which
i'm also going to define as text a url
which again is going to be some text
and now i'm going to have a primary key
so from our previous lesson we know that
we can search for something in a table
by its primary key
i'm going to choose to search by the
country
the country is actually the partition
key we refer to in the explainer okay so
we have a primary key command and we are
passing through what we want the
partition key to be if that makes sense
so what i have done is chosen one of the
table columns here i have chosen country
to be my partition key and i have passed
that into the primary key like so
so now also what is happening is that
all my data from now on is going to be
distributed in my database based on the
value of country now
the other values here that i have put
so name and url are what we call
clustering keys
so what this means is that when i search
for data based on the partition key so
in this case it's country
i can make it come back in
descending order and url in ascending
order
okay
so there we go
let's go ahead and run that command not
for getting these semicolon and there we
go
next let's actually insert some data
into this table so just like before i'm
going to use the insert to command i'm
going to insert into the table that i
have chosen to call restaurant by
country i'm going to open up some
parenthesis and i'm going to
say that i want to put in a country a
name a cuisine a url
and i'm just going to close that off
and then start a new line with the
values so open up the parenthesis again
and i'm going to put the string of
poland
the name i'm going to put
viewska
as a string
and then the cuisine i'm also going to
put some text for this i'm going to put
traditional as a string
and then the url once again this is a
string
i'm going to put www.kadrama.pl
and close that off and put the semicolon
and click
enter
and wonderful i'm just going to insert
another row while we are here so once
again insert into
my table name is restaurant by country
i'm going to open my parenthesis to say
what exactly i want to put in this row
i'm going to put in a country a name
a cuisine
and a url
and in the next slime i'm going to put
the values
this time let's put
singapore
and i'm going to put
this shack as a string this is going to
be american food as a string and the url
is going to be www.shack.sg
and i'll close that off
and wonderful hit enter
great
we can also do a third one so i'm just
going to actually press up this time
which will just bring back the last line
and for the values i'm just going to
replace that with united kingdom
and for this one let's
put the red rose
and i'm going to put pub as the cuisine
and as the url let's just put red rose
dot
co dot u k and wonderful
so now click enter
and great
let's check if that has worked so i'm
going to use the select command this
time select all
so the asterisk is all from restaurant
by
country because that is the table name i
want to get everything from the table
oops i need to post a semicolon and
great there is our table this is looking
good
and once again let's try getting one
thing from the table
so select
or from restaurant by country so the
table name where the country equals the
string singapore
okay and then just put some semicolons
and hit
enter
and that should return back the singular
restaurant so the shack because that has
the partition key of singapore wonderful
now what do you think happens if we add
another row that also has the country
singapore well
let's check it out for this part i'm
going to involve you i'm going to break
to an exercise
so what i want you to do is actually add
another line so another row to our table
that has the country singapore
the name of the restaurant the heart the
url www hut
and cuisine lebanese
okay
so go ahead and add one row to our
existing table but before we do that i'm
going to ask you to refresh the page so
go ahead and click that
and
wonderful go ahead i'm going to pause
here while you have a go at doing this
yourself before we carry on together
okay
so first things first you can of course
use the describe key spaces command to
list out all the key spaces in your
database or you can just go straight to
it if you know which key space you want
to use
so i'm going to choose use tabular just
like so making sure that i am in the
tabular key space
next i'm going to essentially insert a
row into the table restaurant by country
so i'm going to do so like so
first things first i'm going to use the
insert
into command and i'm going to insert
into
restore
by
country
just like so because that is the name of
our table and i'm going to insert a
country i'm also going to insert a name
i'm going to insert some cuisine
and a url
okay so that's what i'm going to do and
i'm just going to make a new line so
don't put the semicolons yet insert into
restaurant by country and then i'm going
to put in values
and the values are going to be
a string of singapore
and then the name we said is going to be
the hut
the url is going to be
dot
www.hut.s
and
the cuisine which is the one we missed
i'm just going to go back it's going to
be lebanese
okay so let's have a look make sure that
it's all correct
okay great and hit enter
so now we have a look at everything so
select everything from
restaurant by
country
there we go you will see that line has
been added a new row has been added so
now if we do select
everything
from
restaurant we could actually just press
up
and then we go where and then we're
going to get the partition key so
country equals
singapore
what do you expect will happen
we get back the two restaurants that are
in singapore
wonderful
so that is essentially how you would
group data together in your table and
retrieve that group data back
now it's time to move on and look at
document database types
document or document orientated database
types are arguably one of the easiest
types to deal with this is because they
require no schema so before in the
tabular database we had to define the
columns that made up our table with this
we don't have to do any of that as long
as our data comes as an object it's fine
the objects are made up of keys and
values and look like this
so this is an example of perhaps an item
you might find in a to-do list
so here you have an object which i have
given an id with a 0 a title with fixed
bike as a string description with a
string and done which i have in this
case given a boolean but that is not
strict the values can be strings numbers
booleans arrays or even objects
themselves
this is called json or javascript object
notation and is the most popular format
for document database types
now a group of documents is called a
collection so we will not be using the
word tables anymore it has been replaced
by collections so keep that in mind
moving forward
so what are we waiting for let's get to
it in this next section i'm going to
make a collection of to do items using a
document api
now for those of you who haven't heard
of the term api let's do a quick crash
course first
an api stands for application
programming interface they allow for
technologies to essentially talk with
each other and are essential to so many
services we rely on today
they are behind most arts we use on a
day-to-day basis and they can shape the
information passed between one
technology to another and they connect
things such as our cars fridges pens or
anything really to the internet apis are
everywhere
as a developer you might use the twitter
api to get live tweets on your site a
map api that will allow us to get data
from a third party to use in our new
delivery app we are building or even use
them in a two-way stream to get post or
delete data from a customer relationship
management system for example there's a
reason why these words are popping up
and let's go into why
in this next section you're going to be
seeing these words and using them to
communicate with the database you make
in this context they are called http
request methods
the most common are the get request
post request
put request and delete request there are
others too but for the sake of the
tutorial these are the ones you need to
know
get essentially gets data and that's all
it does
so imagine you have a client or in other
words your computer and a server
you are on your computer and the url
which is where you want to get your data
from is on a server
the client
so once again your computer
sends an http get request to the server
to retrieve the data we want
so here we have a get request or a
visualization of a get request
the client is requesting the server
gives it the necessary resources we need
then after the server has sent the
response so request and response
we say that we've
got it
thank you
after the server sends a response it
closes something called a tcp or
transmission control protocol connection
we also have post requests and
put requests
so here we have a visualization of how
the request would work with post
requests so simply sending something to
the server and with put requests which
are the same we are sending something to
the server but essentially to edit
something or override it we will go into
this in the next section
and of course a delete request too a
delete request will essentially delete
something that is pointed to in our url
or endpoint
so
to get interacting with my data you will
see these different
end points
simply put an endpoint is where a
resource lives
so with this end point here forward
slash burgers i will get all my burgers
i can also create a burger to the same
end point
to create a bagger however i use the
post
http method as we
discussed i can also edit a singular
burger also as we discussed
and of course we have delete which you
guessed it will delete a singular burger
if we provide the end points with the id
okay so hopefully this theoretical
example has made sense let's get to
using our knowledge in our project okay
the first thing we're going to do is
actually create a new key space i'm
going to call this key space document
i'm just going to go here and save it
and there we go
okay so now we've got two key spaces i'm
going to keep the workload separate so
one for tabula i'm with a document
because we're going to be working with
document types in this section
so to do this i'm going to choose to
connect to my database using the
document api
however before we do that we're going to
have to get a token in order to
communicate with our database so to do
this i'm just going to go to settings
and then under application tokens
organization settings click that
the role i'm going to select as an admin
user and i'm going to generate a token
so this is the token we are going to use
please of course do use your own i will
be deleting this after this tutorial
so just go ahead and copy that and make
sure to store it somewhere safe
okay
great
now once you've done that just go back
and this time we're not going to use the
sql console we're going to use this
connect tab and we're going to use the
document api to connect to our database
okay
so all i'm going to do
is launch swagger and this will launch
some swagger docs for us that will be
useful in communicating with our
database okay so this is all pre-made
for us there's not much we're gonna have
to do we're just gonna have to fill out
some blanks
the first thing i'm gonna do is actually
create a new empty collection in a
namespace
okay so before as mentioned we work with
tables
now we're going to be working in
collections okay so once again we were
working with tables before
now we're going to work with collections
so i'm going to create a new empty
collection in the namespace and just
click try it out
and all i'm going to do is fill out all
of these empty spaces that have been
created for us while we are here it's
actually important to note that you can
write your own code for these requests
so at the moment we are on a post
request i will be showing you how to do
this in the project portion of this
course for now we're just going to make
use of this pre-configured ui to help us
make these requests
so all i'm going to do is actually put
in my cassandra token in here so that's
the one that we just created
and under the namespace id
well
we know that our namespace that we just
created or in other word a key space is
called document
so that's what we put in here document
okay not tabular document
and next we're going to have to put
something in the body of our request
okay so we're going to have to put in
some json with the name of the
collection
so all i'm going to do is choose what i
want to call my collection and i'm going
to choose to call it
my
first
collection just like so okay so you open
up some curly braces this is how jason
looks we open up some curly braces we
put the string of name as we were
prompted to and the string of my first
collection
wonderful
so now we can scroll down
and just click execute
and then wait for our response
and as you can see that has returned
with a status code
201 okay status code 201 so that has
worked
if you don't know about status codes
there is a really handy website that i'm
going to show you with all the status
codes that could return it illustrates
them with little dogs and is really easy
to understand this is something that i
use quite a lot in my day-to-day
developer life
okay so we have now created a collection
called my first collection let's carry
on
just going to delete all of this
and cancel that
and now the next thing i want to do is
put something in our collection right so
i'm going to create a new document to do
this
once again i'm just going to click try
it out and i'm going to fill out all of
these
spaces so once again let's put in the
token that we just created
next we need the namespace or as it's
called on our platform the key space so
once again i'm going to put document
and in the collection id
well the collection that i want to put
this in is called my first collection as
we just created and in the body in the
body i'm going to put in my first item
into the collection and this is what i
want it to look like okay so once again
we have the curly braces i've got the
string of id which i'm going to give it
as one i'm going to give it the title of
make
dinner
and then the description of make dinner
to apologize
for
breaking
my housemates bike and done is a boolean
of fuss
okay so this is the first document i
want to put into my collection it's just
an object that has some information okay
i can make this information whatever i
wish
so this is what my information looks
like
let's carry on
i'm just gonna click execute
and there we go we get a 201 code and
that has responded we also get a
response with this which is the document
id so the document we just created the
one with id1 the one about making dinner
has this document id this is its
identifier in our collection
okay
great
now let's get to using this id
so now i'm going to show you how to do
two things i'm going to show you how to
search for everything in a collection
and i'm then going to show you how to
search for one thing in a collection
so let's start off with the first one
first let's search for everything in a
collection
to do this i'm going to just select
search documents in a collection
and once again i'm just going to put in
the cassandra token let's click try out
i'm also going to put in the namespace
or key space as it's called on our
platform so i'm going to put in document
for the collection i'm simply going to
put my first collection
and then i'm just going to execute it
okay so i'm just going to scroll down
and hit
execute
and there we go we get a status code 200
and we also get the response body so
that is responding with all the data in
our collection at the moment there's
only one item okay so it might be a bit
hard to tell you might think it's just
bringing about one item but it's in fact
bringing back all the items in our
collection
great
now i'm going to show you how to pick
out an item based on the document id so
the thing we created in the part just
previous to this so to do this i'm
actually going to use the document id so
let's just go ahead and grab that
and then let's go to get a document
once again let's click try it out
i'm going to put in the document id and
then i'm just going to fill this out so
once again the collection i'm looking in
is called my first collection
and then the namespace
is called document
and the cassandra token well we just
need to paste that in
and click execute
and great so we're returning that one
item from our
collection
okay base by its document id
okay so now that i've shown you how to
create a collection add a document to
collection get all the documents back
and just search for one document in the
collection by document id i'm just going
to show you how you would do this in the
project part
so all we're going to do or essentially
all that is happening here on this
platform is that we are constructing a
url okay so every time you fill out a
field you are constructing this long url
as you can see here we've populated it
with a namespace a collection and a
document id
so this is exactly what we will be doing
in the project part we're going to be
making a request to this url however
with authorization so at the moment if i
just take this url
and i paste it in the browser
you will get a message that says role
unauthorized for this operation missing
token okay there are tools that we can
use to help us if we do want to view
this before building our project one
tool that comes to mind is a tool called
hopscotch that i use quite often
and then all you would do so i'm just
going to gravitate to hopscotch.io
and i'm simply just going to create a
new request here
so all i'm going to do is put in the url
that we just created
making sure that the method is a get
request
okay
because we are getting the data and i'm
simply going to put the cassandra token
that we have so the one that we've saved
the really long one in the header so
once again i'm going to get that token
i'm first actually going to get x
cassandra token so we can identify it
and then i'm going to paste my long
token okay once again make sure that
this is a get request because we are
getting data from the database and click
send
wonderful
so now we get a status code 200 and we
also get some response we get the
response body to be the document we have
just created
great
before we move on i'm just going to show
you how to do one more thing and that is
search for something by a filtered field
so what i can do i'm just going to go to
search all documents again
and in here i'm just going to add a
where string so this to jog your memory
is how we return all the documents back
from a database i can also filter out
which one so i can filter them out by
title so for example i can choose to
filter out so this is the syntax for
filtering out i can choose to filter out
by say title
and anything with the title
of
make dinner will be returned back to me
so once again i'm just going to do that
that is the syntax for filtering out all
of my documents and searching for anyone
that has the title make dinner or any
multiple ones that have the title made
dinner and then click execute
and anything with the title meet dinner
will be returned back to me
okay
great
okay so now that we have done that time
for a little exercise
based on all the learning that we have
done so far how would you go about
creating a new item to put in our
collection so at the moment we have one
item in our collection called my first
collection i would like to add another
so which of these do you think i should
go to
that's right i would need to make a post
request to this url and replace
namespace id and collection id as well
as provide my authorization token
so
let's go ahead and do it
i'm just going to refresh this so we can
start anew and click here
so once again i'm just going to click
here to try it out
under the cassandra token i'm just going
to put in my token
the namespace id or as we know the key
space id is called document
and then the collection id is called my
[Music]
first
collection
and now we need to create our document
so i'm going to create an object for
this i could simply just have an id like
so let's give it the id of two
and then a description
[Music]
and then make it clean dishes after
dinner and if i executed that that would
work however i have chosen to keep all
my objects the same that is a personal
choice
so let's go ahead and add a title
i'm gonna make the same title that i did
last time and i will show you why
so there we go title description and
then done i'm going to give it the
value
of false that does not need to be in
quotation marks that is a boolean value
that i'm signing to the property done
okay
so now if i click execute
we get a 201 code with the response body
that's come back with the document id
for this document right here
okay
so we've added one more item i'm just
going to add another item let's make
this id 10.
let's give it a different title so fix
shoes
and
take
choose to be
fixed
with done false and once again i'm just
going to execute that
so what that means is i now have three
items in my collection called my first
collection
two of them have the title mcdinner and
one has the title fixed shoes
now if i wanted to bring back all the
documents with the title make dinner so
all of them associated with making
dinner how would i
do this
so once again three items in my
collection i only want to bring back two
and that includes the ones that have the
title make dinner
that's right i would have to make a get
request to this url so replace the
namespace id the collection id and
provide an authorization token so once
again i'm just going to click to try
this out i'm going to grab the cassandra
token the namespace id i want to look at
is called document or in other words the
key space name the collection id i'm
going to look at is called my first
collection
and this is the syntax for filtering out
i want to filter out by title
and i want to make sure that that title
is equal
making sure to put this in quotation
marks equal to make
dinner which is case sensitive
okay
so that's the syntax and what do i
expect to come back i'm actually going
to set the page size let's just make it
max 20 so if i had more than two for
example and i only wanted 20 to come
back this is how i would do it and then
i'm just gonna click execute
and there we go so now we can see that
two
items have come back to us
this one and this one and we do not see
the item that has the title fix shoes
great
and once again all we have done is
generated this url by filling out all of
the above okay so what i am doing is
there we go we see the namespace has
been replaced you will see the
collection name has been replaced and if
we look where well we are looking for a
title
equal
to make
dinner
and we only want to bring back max 20
items
wonderful
so i hope you've learned a lot in this
section please do pause here i can't
stress enough how much i recommend
pausing here and having a play around
with all the different requests you can
make so for example if you want to
delete a document or update a document
too
please have a play around with that and
once you are done i will see you in the
next section
in this next section we are going to
look at the key value databases they are
considered to be the easiest database
type and usually come looking like this
so you have a key column and then you
have a value column you can actually
have as many value columns as you wish
the important thing here is that we can
retrieve data back to us so an entire
row by the key as that is the identifier
in this case
let's have a quick look at an example of
a key value database and how to make one
next
okay so i'm going to click here and just
add key value
and click
save
okay great so we can now see another key
space has been added
now this time i'm going to use graphql
just as a little bit of something
different in order to create our key
value
table
okay so this time i'm going to choose to
connect using the graphql api just
purely because we've already worked with
the document api so i'm going to click
here
and just launch the graphql playground
just like so
now
the first thing we need to do when we
are here is to create a new table
so first off i'm actually going to put
in my cassandra token so i'm able to
communicate with my database so i'm just
going to grab it
just like so
and now you should be able to see the
documents populate with all the queries
and mutations that we can do
so as i said i want to create a table so
let's go ahead and do that
this is a mutation as it's under the
mutations tab and to create a table i'm
just going to write create
table
i need to pass through the following
things so a key space name a table name
partition keys and values
so the key space name i'm just going to
put this on a new line
well we know that the key space name is
key value as we've just created it
now the next thing we need to actually
do is give our table a name so i'm gonna
call this shop
inventory just like so
and the partition keys now if you
remember from the first section our
partition keys is essentially the key
that we want to filter our table by or
search for items in our table by and it
says here that this needs to be an array
so that's what we're going to do we're
making an array
and then what do we want our partition
key to be
i'm going to give it the name of
keep
and i'm also going to define the types
that it takes so i'm just going to put
type like so and i'm going to pass
through
basic text
great
so we have our key space name we have
our table name we have our partition
keys next let's put in the values as you
will see these all have a bang after
them so they are required
values is not required but we're going
to need it for our table so once again
i'm just going to put a comma
and put in values
and this needs to be an array
so i'm going gonna open up the array
and i only want uh another one column so
at the moment we've got one column which
is a key the next column i want to have
is values
so i'm going to name this
value
and once again i'm just going to give
this the type of
basic
text
just
like
so
and if we click here
wonderful we have created our table
great
so we created our table the next thing
i'm going to do is add keys and values
to our table
so
i'm just going to go ahead and delete
this
and instead of having graphql schema i'm
going to have graphql
forward slash and i'm just going to put
in the
key space so key value just like
so and wonderful so now we're in the
key space key value i'm going to use
another mutation so you will see here
the mutations and queries have changed
because i can do a bunch of other stuff
i'm going to use the
insert
shop
inventory okay
so that is what i'm going to do and
start mutation as this is a mutation
and i'm just going to say shop
insert shop inventory just like so and
i'm going to use this to insert items
into my
table
so i need to open up some parenthesis
and then in here well i want to pass
through a value
and that's going to have my key so what
key can we give this i'm just going to
put in a string as we said it needs to
be text and i'm just going to choose to
give it this key so this identifier just
like so and then the value of
let's have beans
so what i'm saying with this code is
that i want to put in this row into my
table that i have just created and the
row will have the key of this
and the value of beans meaning that if i
want to search for beans in my table i
would use this identifier okay
so
i'm just going to also have to
return something so we know this works
so i'm just going to return the
key and the
value
and click here
wonderful
so now we know that we have inserted
this one item into our shop inventory
into our table that we have called shop
inventory let's just add another item so
i'm just going to make this random once
again and then another item we can put
in is shampoo
and just click here
great
so now i'm going to actually retrieve
this data but first off i just want to
show you what this looks like if we use
the cqr console okay so i'm going to go
back here
and under the cql console
well i am just going to write
use key value because we need to get the
key space and once we are here i'm going
to use the command describe table
shop
inventory
okay so we can see here we have added
that table that table exists and exists
in the key space key value
and now if i want to grab everything
from the table well hopefully you
remember this from the first lesson
select all this essentially means all
from
shop
inventory
making sure that i spelt it correctly
inventory
and there we go
we have a table that has a key and a
value and we can find any item in our
table so any row by the partition key or
the key right here
great
okay
so hopefully you can see how we can make
tables using the key and value approach
just while we're here i'm going to show
you how to retrieve all the data
uh from our table using graphql as well
just in case you are not familiar with
graphql this time i'm going to have to
have a query so i'm going to write query
just like so and i'm going to look in
the shop
inventory
okay so i'm looking in the shop
inventory and what do i want to return
well if i just want everything then i
would simply put
values
key
value
and click
enter
and there we go we are getting all the
items from our shop inventory table
okay
so if you want to use this in the
project and you want to get all the
items from your shop inventory this is
the query that you would use wonderful
okay
before we move on i'm just going to do a
little exercise to see if you've
remembered what we've learned so
i'm just going to get rid of this
if i want to add one more item into the
shop inventory how would i do this and
what two things do i need to check
well first off we need to check that we
are in the correct url
okay so we need to make sure that the
url is pointing to the key space
in this case it's key value because that
is what i call my key space and that i
also have my cassandra token in the
header okay so those are the two things
you need to check and once you have
checked that we can write a mutation
okay not a query a query essentially
retrieves back data and a mutation adds
data deletes data or edits data
so for this because we are adding a new
item into our shop inventory i need to
write a
mutation and that mutation is insert
shop inventory because i'm inserting
into the table called shop inventory
okay and what do we need to put in here
well we need the values of
key
and value
and what are we going to have is the key
well once again i'm just going to put in
a random string like that as an
identifier and the value this time i'm
gonna put
i don't know coca cola
okay
great and just to check this has worked
i'm going to return the values of
key and value
i could technically just return one it
is up to you and just click here
so now because that has returned we know
that has worked
brilliant
now how do you think and this is
something we haven't covered so this is
going to require you to have a little
bit of think based on what i've told you
how do you think we would delete an item
from the shop inventory
well that's right because we are
changing the data we're going to have to
find a mutation that will delete from
our shop inventory and because we find
stuff by the partition key so this we
are probably going to have to delete an
item by searching for this key right
here
so let's check it out so i know this is
going to be a mutation and i can also
look in the docs to find the delete
shop inventory mutation
to help me out so that is a mutation
that i need
delete shop inventory and i'm just going
to pass through the values of
okay
i'm just going to grab this one right
here
and i'm just going to return the value
of key
okay and that should have worked let's
go have a look here
and once again i'm just going to chop
list out everything in my shop inventory
and amazing so we added the coca-cola
and then we deleted the coca-cola too
great
now if i was to say try delete something
by the value so let's go ahead and put
shampoo and then just return the value
we will get an error this is because we
cannot delete by the value we have to
delete by the primary key which we set
to be the key
okay
wonderful so i hope you've learned a lot
in this section and i'll see you in the
next one
in this next section we are going to
look at graph databases
graph databases are a great way to store
data that has relationships between
other pieces of data or in other words
notes
each node is connected by an edge to
represent this relationship
think for example your friends on social
media here is you and here are three of
your friends so you and your friends are
nodes and the connection you have is
represented by this line whereas we are
going to call it from now on an edge
easy right but wait your friends can
also be friends with each other so how
would we represent that well by adding
more edges to represent the
relationships and as your friendship
circle expands the more complex it can
get
so that is the simple idea behind how
graph databases work let's see it in
action
in this section we will be doing an
overview of an already existing
demograph database the github repository
for following along will be given to you
in the description below so once it gets
to that please go ahead and find it
below
okay
so this time we are not going to be
using the data sucks astra interface
we're going to be using the data stacks
enterprise graph okay
so let's go to it
for this part you're going to have to
have docker installed so please go ahead
and download docker if you don't have it
already install it onto your machines
okay so once you have it installed it
should look something like this
all you need to do when you're here is
just click these settings and make sure
that
the
cpu the memory the swap and the disk
image size are all around about these
levels okay so that is what you need to
do make sure that you have at least two
cpu so here you see you have eight and
at least three gigabytes or ram
so these are the settings you need once
you have them let's carry on
and once you have that done i'm just
going to ask you to get up your terminal
and then in whatever directory you wish
please write the following command
so please go ahead and write the command
docker network
create
graph and click enter
so what you should have is this long
id right here
okay
so
once you have that we are now ready to
carry on this is your identifier for the
graph
the next thing i'm going to ask you to
do is clone this directory so this is
directory i will be putting at the
bottom in the description so just clone
the datastax devs workshop introduction
to nosql and click
enter
now i already have that in here so i'm
just going to go into the directory
cd workshop introduction to nosql and
once we are in here we are free to start
the container
so what i'm going to do is
docker
compose
up
d
and then wait for that to open up in the
localhost 9091
so this will take a while please feel
free to pause here have a break and
let's get back to it once all of this is
complete
okay great and now let's go ahead and
visit localhost
9091
okay so this is an example from
datasites itself please feel free to use
it and adapt it as you wish
and there we go so this is what you
should see here is the example that is
given to us from data stacks let's go
ahead and first check our connections so
i'm just going to click here and on
connections it's going to click on this
one right here and just make sure that
this is on dsc
okay
so this essentially is pointing to our
local cassandra so once that is done
let's test it out
and great so we are connected
successfully let's carry on
now let's go back to here and just click
on this example one
like so
now you will see that you're prompted to
create a graph so let's go ahead and
create our first graph i'm just going to
keep it as studio tutorial graph like so
so just leaving all the default settings
okay and i'm just going to click create
wonderful our first graph is now created
now if we move down here you will see a
language called gremlin okay this is the
language that we are going to use for
this tutorial it is essentially another
query language okay so we've looked at
sql we've looked at cql and now we have
gremlin it is a graph traversal language
okay and it has been developed by apache
tinker pop of the apache software
foundation
with this language we are essentially
creating schema okay so just like we
have been doing you will see here that
we are adding a schema called god and we
are giving a partition key in this case
it's going to be the name which is some
text and it also has a property which is
age which is an integer and we are
creating it we are also creating a
demigod which has the same partition a
human again which has a partition key of
name a monster a location and a titan
okay so here we have the code in order
for us to essentially create our first
graph all about gods and demigods and
monsters
so i'm just going to click here to run
this so run this in real time
and wonderful that has been a success
so now if we look down to here
you will see some more code again in the
language gremlin
so just like we created labels here of
god demigod human monster we have now
also included edges so these edges are
essentially how each one is going to be
related so this edge is called father so
this is going to show us a relationship
of father and son or daughter and then
also we have mother and brother two and
it will also give us the direction so a
god is essentially the father of a
demigod but also can be the father of a
god if someone is a titan
okay
so that is how that looks let's carry on
if we move down we can see more edge
labels okay so we can also write a
relationship of who's battled who as
well as father and brother we can also
do where someone lives or if someone's a
pet and so on
and finally we can actually add items to
our graph so this is how you would add
some items into a graph so for example
here we are adding satin we are saying
this is a titan we are giving it the
property name of saturn and we are
giving an age of 10 000 and so on and we
do this for all these other items as
well okay so there we go we are defining
the items and we are defining the
relationships between the items or in
other words the edges between the notes
and finally we can have a table of what
this looks like as well so here we can
see this in table format but what is
more interesting is the graph view
so this is essentially what our
information looks like once it has been
graphed out with nodes and edges so the
edges symbolize the relationship so if
we have a deeper look at this we can
actually click on these and it will give
us more information so for example this
is a monstro hydra you will see the name
it has is hydra you'll also see it has
the label monster and by its node you
will see that it's battled the monster
serbius okay so there we go this is a
great example of how grass can really
illustrate information in an amazing way
now this has been a lot shorter than the
other tutorials this is because i just
wanted to show you how you can work with
graph databases it will involve learning
the gremlin language but i think this is
a good place to start in order to get
your head around it so i'm going to
leave this information to you i'm going
to put the link in the description and
please do have a go at getting this up
yourselves and i'm going to play around
with it as well so if we want to add one
more thing into our database we can do
it right here and just don't forget to
run it
so now because there isn't much of an
exercise here i'm just going to give you
a pop quiz when working with graphs what
would these be called so these right
here that i am pointing at
this little red guy right here these
monsters and this god
these will be called notes and what
connects the nodes
that's right edges so once again these
are the edges and if we actually
gravitate over them in this ui it will
give us the relationship between each
note
okay so as we can see here we have a
little house
the location is the sky and then this is
where
jupiter
lives because he loves the fresh breezes
wonderful
okay so i think we are done with looking
at graphics to power this down i'm just
gonna run a command it's gonna be
docker
compose dump and just hit enter
great
so that is all four of the database
types i think we're now ready to move on
with some projects
now that we have covered the four main
database types i want to quickly talk to
you about the multimodal type
in this course let's actually recap what
we've done well we created a database
right and in it we stored the key value
pairs as per the first tutorial after
that we stored json documents in astrodb
as per the document type tutorial we
then stored data in tables as another
tabular tutorial section too and finally
we stored graph data so that's a variety
of different data models all stored in
one place by the graph one all of this
is possible because astrodb is actually
a multi model nosql database you can use
the same database to store a variety of
data models but what is cool about this
is that you also only need to learn and
maintain one database which makes your
job easier learn one database and use it
to solve many different problems
okay wonderful now hopefully through the
explanations examples and exercises you
are now feeling a lot more confident is
not only understanding the different
types of nosql database types but also
how to use them if not don't worry i
have two short real-life projects that
we are going to build in order to show
you how you would interact with your
databases when building javascript
projects
by using a data api gateway like
stargate io cassandra and astrodb
developers can opt to use a graphql rest
or schema-less json document api as an
alternative to cql
let's do it
okay and let's get to it in this project
i'm going to be showing you how to use
the document type as well as the
document api in order to create our
first project
this project is going to be a app which
will show you all your favorite burger
restaurants okay
so let's get to it i've actually started
with a fresh board so you will notice
there are no key spaces and we're going
to have to go ahead and create our
database again
so i'm just going to go here
and let's call our database
project
work and our key space
burgers and then once again i'm just
gonna have to create the area that i am
in
and create a database
wonderful so you will see my
database is being created and you will
see the status is pending i'm just going
to wait for that to be active so that i
can go ahead and start using it
and wonderful the status is now active
let's go ahead and use our database so
to do this i'm just going to double
click in here
and you'll see the key space name of
burgers
now let's get to adding some data i'm
going to do this thanks the document api
as stated so first off we need to create
a token so i'm just going to click in
here
and the role i'm going to choose is
admin user and i'm just going to create
a token
once again please make sure to keep this
token safe i would strongly recommend
saving it somewhere useful
okay so once we have that let's go back
to this documentation right here
let's go ahead and launch the swagger ui
so i'm just going to go ahead and click
that and these should populate in front
of you
so we have a lot of options here a lot
of end points if you remember from the
tutorial the one i need first is this
one right
here we need to create a collection in
order to store our data so i'm just
going to go ahead and click that and
click try it out
once again i'm just going to paste the
cassandra token in here so that we can
essentially communicate with the
database and then let's go ahead and
choose the name space or in other words
the key space we want to create our
collection in
as we have just created it this is fresh
in my mind and i know that the key space
name is
burgess
wonderful
and in here we just have to pass through
an object that has the name
and then whatever we want to call our
collection so i'm going to call this
burger
info
just
like
so
and i'm just going to click
execute
and great we get a 201 code we've made a
request to this url
with our new authorization token and the
status code we got back was 201 or in
other words let's have a look at the
status docs again
or in other words 2014 created
great
so now that we have created our
collection what's the next thing we need
to do
the next thing we need to do is
add some documents into the collection
so i'm going to go ahead and do it by
selecting this one right here it is a
post request to this url
so once again i'm going to choose to try
it out i'm going to paste in my
cassandra token
the namespace or the key space id that
we want to communicate with is called
burgers
the collection id we just created is
called burger
info and then the body is essentially
the document that we want to put into
our burger info
so i'm going to choose for my document
to look like this
i'm going to give each restaurant a name
so for example bob's
burgers
so that is a string i've chosen to give
it the string of bob's burgers i'm also
going to give it a
description
and i'm going to say
tasty
burgers
from a
fictional
character
from
tv
so we've got the name we've got
description we can also have ingredients
and we can do this if we wish as an
array so in here i'm going to put a
patty so beef
patty
i'm also going to put tomato
let's also put some cucumber
some lettuce
and some
cheese
okay
so those are my ingredients i don't only
have to put strings in here i can also
put an array of strings if
i wish
okay
and one last thing that i want to show
you is
okay we can also have boolean so i can
have visited
and i can have true
and then i can also
visit it
have objects within objects so if i put
location
like so as a property
i can have an object as a value
so that is also an option um let's go
ahead and do that i'm just going to open
up my
objects and in here
i can have so location
address and then have that to be
a string if i wish
so 45
lavender
drive i can also have a
let's do zip code
which is an integer so i'm going to make
this up
and then i can also have
the web
address
so this is just going to be
www.bobsburgers.com
okay just
like that
so we have a string here we have a
string here we have an array of strings
we have a boolean we also have an object
which has an address a zip code as an
integer
and a web address as a string
now let's have a look and see if this is
working we can also give it a unique id
if we don't want it to count from zero
so perhaps let's go ahead and do that
i'm just going to go ahead and
maybe let's start from
340 why not
okay
so now let's execute this
and great our first document has been
created and we also get a document id
that has been assigned to this object
right here
so we have one let's go ahead and add
another so i can just do so from here
let's go id 341
this time let's go
matilda's
and
matthews
manhattan
burger
joint
and then let's change this up they have
a
tofu patty
tomatoes
let's have a pickle
so pickles
let's also have some lettuce and then we
can have bree
visited i'm gonna put as false
and the location let's change this up so
i'm just going to put in a random
location let's put
denver
avenue
zip code once again i'm just going to
make this up
and then let's put
m and m
progress
and just
click
execute
great
so we have two documents in our burger
info collection let's just add two more
so i'm just going to change the id again
and then
let's have
go truths
place
hipster
hang out in
the
city as the description and i'm gonna
have a
beef patty
let's have perhaps something else here
so coal slaw
pickles
lettuce and there's cheese let's have
cheddar
visited i'm going to have as true and
the location let's have 103
darling turn
drive
once again just make up the zip code
go
towards
place.com and just click
execute
let's go ahead and just add one more
so there we go
and then let's have
fancy burgers
a new location for
burger snobs
some beef patty
let's also have a
onion
ring in this one
some pickles some lettuce and
let's just have some generic
cheese visited i'm gonna put as false
location i'm gonna put
one
water
street
let's make this up
and have
fancy
progress
dot com
and click execute
great
so now we have four burgers in here but
let's just double check this has worked
so to get all of our burgers back i'm
going to search documents in a
collection so i'm just going to go here
this will be a get request as i'm
getting the data i'm just going to paste
in my token right here i'm going to look
in
burgers and that is what i called my key
space the collection id is called burger
info
and then i'm going to say that i'm going
to have a max of 20 come back and i'm
just going to click
execute and there we
go we can see all four of our
burgers coming back to us
great
so that is exactly the data that we need
now let's get to using this in a project
so essentially what i want to do is
build a project in which i'm going to be
making a request to this url right here
and passing through my authorization
token so
let's do it
i'm just going to go ahead and open up
webstorm
so i'm going to get up my webstorm
project
and i'm going to say this is a react
project so let's call this burger
app just like so and i'm going to use
the create react app command in order to
build out a react project for me all
configured so we can go
so i'm just going to click create
and as you can see that command has
sprung into action and i'm essentially
just downloading all the dependencies
fetching all the dependencies and
packages that i need in order to get the
boilerplate for my react project
of course if you're not using webstorm
please go ahead and get to this point as
well all you need to do is create a
project in your directory using the
command npx create react app
great
so now that we have that let's get to it
so as you can see here the npx creator
react app has essentially populated all
this for me with the following packages
and written these following scripts okay
so these are the dependencies that have
been installed
and these are the files i've come with
create react app
so if i actually run this i'm just going
to go ahead and click npm start
like so
this is essentially what should show up
on localhost 3000 okay
so that is something that you should be
seeing right now
if i go ahead and actually delete all
these files so i'm actually going to go
ahead and just do some deleting so here
is our app this is essentially the
spinner that we saw so you will see here
the spinner is
this right here
i'm going to go ahead and delete all of
this like so
um if i actually just go hello i'm going
to show you how this looks
okay as you can see that is working so
that is updated
so i'm just going to delete this for now
i don't need the logo so i'm actually
going to get rid of that
i don't like to use semicolon so i'm
just going to delete that and i like to
use
functional expressions so i'm just
changing this as this is my preference
but you are free to keep it as uh as you
wish
so there we go we don't need the logo so
i'm just gonna go ahead and delete that
from this project
we don't need the report vitals so i'm
going to delete that
delete anyway
let's delete the tests as well as we're
not going to be writing tests for this
project
and let's delete this test file too
okay
great
i don't also need i'm actually going to
delete the css file as i'm going to be
doing all my css in this index css file
so i'm going to delete this i'm just
going to put all my styling in one file
for this
project
so there we go there's our app.js file
and if we look in here we don't need
this as we've just deleted it we don't
need this as that is now non-existent
and once again i'm just going to get rid
of the
semicolons
like
so
okay wonderful let's just check we
didn't break anything and this is
looking
good
let's get my console log out too
okay
so now that we have a blank slate let's
get to actually getting our data so to
do this i'm going to have to create a
little mini back end
so just in the root of my project so on
the same level as git ignore i'm going
to create a new file
just a new file like this and i'm going
to call it index j s
okay
so there we go this is essentially going
to be my mini back end in which i'm
going to build a back end using express
so first things first let's decide what
port we want our back end to run on
i'm going to decide that i want my port
to run on 80 000 8 000 sorry
and we're going to have to install a few
dependencies for this one of them will
be expressed so we're going to use
express for this project i'm going to
use require express so i'm just going to
get up my terminal and install
express like so i'm also going to need
cause morgan
node fetch so we can do fetching in the
back end and dot env for storing secret
variables okay so please go ahead and
just install these dependencies and i'll
talk you through them as we use them
okay so i'm just going to leave that to
install and let's go ahead and just
uh
actually use them in the back end of the
project so require the package course
and then const morgan
equals
require
morgan morgan is actually a package that
we're going to use in order to
i'm going to show you what it looks like
so i'm just going to go mpm morgan it's
essentially going to help us debug the
back end better and make everything a
little bit more readable so this is the
package if you want to have more of a
look it's essentially a little logger
that will give us more information when
we use it and once we do use it in our
project so once we do essentially
do this so we're using the package or
storing it as morgan we've done the same
we then need to pass tiny into morgan
okay so this is essentially what is
going to let us debug better
so as you can see i've got the package
and i'm storing it under the const
morgan and i'm just going to use morgan
and pass through tiny so we can
use the logger better
great
so we've got morgan the next thing i
need is a package called node fetch and
this essentially works sort of similar
to the fetch api
and will allow me to make fetch requests
on the backend so just like that that's
how i'm going to use fetch
just to be sure that everyone is using
the same packages please be sure to be
using these packages that i have right
here there could have been updates so to
prevent any issues just make sure that
these are the ones you are using or if
you're in doubt please feel free to
check out my github project that i will
share with you in the description of
this video below
and finally we also need the dot env
to
the dot env package will allow us to
read secrets from the back as well and
this is how you would initiate it okay
so all i'm doing is actually getting
this from the documentation i'm doing
this from memory as i've used these so
many times but if we search here
here we go
as you will see all i'm doing is taking
this and using it in my project in order
to use the dot env package
uh whoops please spell that correctly
dot env
okay
great
so this is looking good now let's
initialize express so the package that i
have just imported and stored as express
i'm now going to initialize like so
so now if i use app like this
i can
use morgan tiny in my back end
i can also
use course
this will essentially stop me from
having cause issues i will show you what
i mean by this when we get to building
our app a little bit further
and then i can also use express
json
okay and this will essentially allow me
to read the json in a way that i can use
it in the back end once again i will
show you what happens when i don't use
this
okay so just make sure to have all of
these like so and all this boilerplate
done so we can start coding
okay so please pause here make a note of
this i'll make it a little bit bigger so
you can see everything a little bit
clearer once again things to remember
are please do make sure your index.js
file is in the root of your project okay
so on the same level as package.json
and then this is the boilerplate setup
that you need in order to get going with
our backend
so the first thing i'm going to do is
get
all the
restaurant
data okay
that's the first thing i'm going to do
and i'm going to show you how
so to do this i'm once again going to
use app
like so so app is essentially
what we saved express as the initialize
expressed as
and now i'm not going to use use i'm
going to use get and what i'm going to
pass through into here is an endpoint
that i'm going to choose okay i'm going
to choose this by myself
i want to say that if i visit
localhost
eight thousand so i'm just going to open
this up in a new tab if i visit
localhost 8000
forward slash
burgers i essentially want the burger
data to show up okay so that's what i'm
writing here by putting forward slash
burgers i'm deciding that this is where
i want my data to populate
okay
great
so that is the first thing i'm going to
do
before we get going actually let's
uh listen out to see if the server's
working so this i would do it once again
you'd use app this time i'm going to use
listen so not use and not get i'm going
to use listen i'm going to listen up to
port
8000
and
if it's all working i'm just going to
console
log out
server is running
on
ports
and then whatever the port number is
okay
so this is looking good let's also write
a script for this because we don't have
at the moment so i'm just going to go in
here
and start front end
so i'm going to keep that script but i'm
going to say start front end needs to be
written in order to start our app so our
front end i'm going to add a new script
so this time if i start
back end like so
then i just want to run the back end so
that's the command to do so
okay
great
so
let's go ahead and i'm gonna stop
this from running
i'm going to change the script to start
front end
and run it
okay so the front end should have
started and now i'm going to open up a
new tab okay there we go so that's just
re-running let's go back to our project
and now i'm going to open up a new tab
so new
tab in our terminal and this time i'm
just going to run this command that i
have written
so npm
run
start back end
okay great and i'm just going to comment
this out for now
comment this out for now because we are
not using it
and
there we go okay server is running on
port eight thousand
so
this is looking good
um obviously at the moment we don't have
anything coming back so i'm just going
to
continue with this
so
if we visit this endpoint what do we
want to do well we want to fetch the
data
so for
this i am actually just going to
don't have a request or a response
let's just have it in here for now and
we want to change that later
and then
okay actually let's just get rid of it
so we just have a function a callback to
be precise we're passing through a
callback
and then we need to essentially
fetch data from the url
so if i just save this as url for now
i'm going to make this a little bit
smaller we essentially want to fetch
data from
this url right here so i'm just going to
copy that
i'm going to paste it as a string like
so okay so that's all i have done for
now
okay we will be tying this up but this
essentially is what this looks like at
the moment
so there's our url now
i need to make a
get this is a get request
so let's go ahead and do
that
so
now it's time to use fetch
so
fetch
takes
a url
okay which is essentially this and we're
also going to have to pass through our
cassandra token okay or our
authorization token so i'm going to do
this along with options so let's define
our options so const options like so
and in here where we know that the
method is a get method okay
and we also need to pass through some
headers
so the headers that we need to pass
through
we need to accept
this like so as a string and we also
need to pass through the x cassandra
token
okay
so we need to pass through essentially
this just like we are passing it through
okay you'll see this is part of the
header okay so essentially what is
happening behind the scenes here we are
now coding out
so i'm just going to once again as a
string post my token
okay
so now when we make a fetch
let's just uncomment this out now when i
fetch i am passing through this url we
are fetching data from this url it is a
get request and we are using this in
order to pass through our cassandra
token
okay
great
so we are making a fetch
and this is going to return a promise
so i then need to chain it with the then
keyword
and the response
it's going to be the response
jason and this is also actually going to
return a promise so we need to chain it
again
and this time i just want to get the
jason
okay so
great
now we do actually need to pass through
a request and response
so let's just do that now
okay so whatever's coming back to us we
need to view as jason and then let's
catch any errors so i'm just going to
catch the errors by console logging out
any errors that return so we can see
just like so
okay
so there we have it there's a lot of
tidying up to do but let's first make
sure that this
works
just make sure that is in the string
itself
cool
so let's give it a
whirl now if i visit
localhost
8000 forward slash burgers this is the
endpoint that i have chosen
ta-da
you will see all my four burgers show up
you will see each object has its own
document id as
well
great
if you're not seeing it in this format
it could be because you don't have a
json view extension added this
essentially will make your your json
much more readable okay so if you don't
have that please go ahead and add the
extension
now this is what it should look like
okay wonderful so we have our data
coming through now let's get it into the
front end but first i'm just gonna tidy
this up real quick so we don't need this
anymore
okay keep that as it is
the url so essentially what we are doing
is
passing through the key space which is
burgers and passing through the
collection
name
okay so you could save it
as separate things and pass it through
so for example i could
save key space as the name
progress and then pass it through into
here with this syntax like so
so i'm just going to go
burgers and then make sure that these
are back ticks
so there we go so that is an option too
if you want to make things oops sorry
that should be keys what do we save this
as key space
key space
so that is an option if you want to make
this more readable or you can and this
is what i'm going to choose to do
because we are not going to be changing
this it's pretty much going to stay
as it is i'm just going to get the whole
url
just like so
and i'm going to save this as a secret
so i'm just going to go in here and once
again on the same level i'm going to
create a new file i'm going to call it
dot
env
okay
and now i'm going to save this in here
as end point
so just
like
so and i'm just going to paste it in
here just like that
so there we go and now to access
this right here i'm going to use process
env
end point
okay
so this wouldn't work if we didn't uh
have this package and didn't use it just
like so
and now i think we have to
re-run this let's just check that out
okay now that seems to be working as it
is
great so we've saved our url as a secret
back here one other thing that i'm going
to save is my astra
token okay
so there we have it
and once again i'm just going to save
all of this
i'm just going to grab that as it is
and use process
env and then whatever we called it
in our
astra
dot env file is what we need to
call it here
so let's save that and i'm just going to
paste that in here like
so
okay
great and that seems to be working just
fine
okay so we've cleaned this up a little
bit
we've got our url we're passing through
the url and the options into fetch
and great
one thing we can do is write some
middleware so if i write function not
found and we pass through the request
the response and next
and then in here
if
we get a four or four status so let's go
back to our status dogs
okay so you will see that 404 means not
found
so if we get a 404
well then
i'm going to
create a new
error
and that error is going to say not
found so we're just making debugging a
bit easier with this we're going to get
the message that says not found okay so
that is what we are going to do and then
if it's none of these
i'm going to move
to the next function
which is just an error handler in
general and it's going to be less
specific
an
error
and blur
i'm going to pass through the error to
this error right here
and then the request and response
and this time if the response if the
status quo is whatever the status quos
is
so whatever it comes back as
or
500 so any error or sorry any stage is
good or 500
then
i want to send a message
that is
whatever comes with that stereoscope
okay so there's two ways of doing it i'm
just going to show you what this means
okay so now let's get to using it so
once again i need to write up use and
i'm going to use the function
not found
and i'm also going to pass through
the function
error
handler just like so
okay so what i've written means that if
i say misspelled this url if i wrote bro
girls like that
i get the message
not found i get the error message
not found however if i didn't have this
so i'm just gonna
comment that out and i go to here
oops
it's actually
do all of these
see it just says cannot get burgers it
doesn't really tell me why it doesn't
give me enough information however if
it's not found
so 404 i'm essentially telling it to
show me an error that says not found
okay
so that is how we do that and then any
other error we get a different error
message so we essentially just get the
error message that goes with these
status quo but this way we can be more
specific so i can go hey you are in the
wrong place buddy
hey you're on the wrong place buddy okay
so cool
just gonna put it back to something
more
general
okay so we are getting all of our
burger data now let's get to using this
in the front end of our project so once
again these are all the packages that i
have used or the dependencies i've used
just make sure that you're using the
same
versions okay
great
now
let's carry on
so essentially for my front end so we
can shut down the back end now
in my front end i essentially want to
get all the data from
this
url so we can use it so let's go ahead
and do
that
to do this i'm actually going to import
another package so i'm just going to get
up my terminal and i'm going to install
the package axios
okay this package is essentially going
to help you make the
requests and fetch the data
so
let's go ahead and do it i'm going to
write a function right in here so a
function to get the data i'm just going
to call it conspiration data
like so so this is a functional
expression
and this is actually going to be an
async function
now to fetch the data i'm going to use
axios so let's import axios
import axios from
axios
once again this is the package that i am
using of axios
so import axios from axios and now i'm
going to use axios and i'm going to make
a get request to get
the url
this url right here okay so because our
back end is running that should work of
course if our backend stops running then
we will not be able to get this data
and this er
we need to
use a weight as that comes back with a
promise and let's save this as
logo
data
just like so
so this should get the data and now i'm
actually going to
save this so i'm going to use use effect
so const
uh burgers
set burgers if you haven't used um
use state sorry use state is the one
that we're going to use and we're going
to use this to set the state in our app
so of course we have to import it so i'm
going to import that just above here
import
use state
we're also going to use use effect so i
might as well just import that too
making sure to spell it correctly
from
react okay
so there we go so essentially if i now
use set burgers
so at the moment our state for burgers
is null but if i use set burgers i can
set
burgers to whatever i wish and i want to
set it to the
burger data
just like
so
okay so let's check this out let's see
if this is working so what i now need to
do i'm just going to use use effect for
this
and i'm going to pass through a callback
function that will essentially fetch my
data
just like so and i was going to pass
through an empty array so that this
doesn't keep on fetching over and over
again
so let's go ahead and do that let's see
if that has worked i'm gonna console log
burgers
and see what happens so let's go back to
our front end so local host 3000
just inspect the page
the console log out
and there we go so this is what burgers
looks like now we actually just want the
data so we're going to go into the
burger data
data
and there we have our four burger
objects
great
so i'm just gonna go ahead and do that
so burger data
data
data
and let's see what that looks like now
okay great so there we have it we
actually have an object of four
objects
cool
so this is looking good um there you go
as you can see there they are with their
ingredients and locations and so on i'd
actually like to make an array out of
this so it's easier to work with so i'm
going to show you how to do
that
so
just here is where i'm going to change
this into an array
let's actually just save this as
data this time
and i'm going to get the burger data
data
and for each
one i'm going to
so let's get the object keys for it so
i'm going to make some object keys for
it because at the moment it doesn't have
anything
uh to
sort of differentiate each of the
objects and i'm going to map
so each
burger object
i'm going to turn into
i'm going to grab it
from the burger data
data
data
and i'm going to turn it into put it
into an
array
okay so now whatever comes back i've
saved that as data and that is what i'm
going to
save as
my burgers and there we go so we now
have an array of four objects each with
an object key
wonderful
um i wonder if i do need these object
keys or if that will just work without
it
no we do need we need the object keys
okay as that's what we are essentially
working off
so
there we go
wonderful so we have our
four
burgers now let's get to actually
displaying them in the browser ui
so let's do it
so for this in here i'm actually just
going to create a data going my
favorite
burgers
the styling for this is going to be
extremely minimal as we have a lot to go
through and i don't want this to be all
about styling i want you to actually
learn how to retrieve data into an
actual project
okay so i'm just going to do this i'm
going to create a div and this is going
to be the burger feed let's maybe give
it a class of burger feed just like so
burger feed
and in here i'm just going to create a
card and this is going to take our
burger data
so let's actually map over each card
let's actually create a card first so in
here i'm actually going to create a
folder or directory called components
so new
directory and it's called components
and then in here i'm going to create a
new file and score card js just like so
and then let's create our card
so const card
and then
i'm going to return
at the moment i'm just going to return
to tags like that and i'm going to use
export default card in order for us to
use this card okay and other files
so now in here i'm going to import the
card import card from
make sure to get the path correct
so in here
components
is that right yep okay
and then
cod.js
cool
we actually don't need the js so this is
fine
so now we've imported the card and at
the moment we aren't passing anything
through into the card however i can
actually style this up so let's go ahead
and i'm just going to give this a class
name just so you can see what's going on
a little bit further and i'm going to
say card
and now in here in my style sheet
anything with the class of card i'm just
going to give a let's give it a height
for now of 200 pixels
a width of
let's say 80 view width
and a background color
of
uh what color should we go corn flower
blue
order
radius
40 pixels
okay
so at the moment i've just put in a card
so there we go that is uh that is my
card now if i map all my data onto this
okay onto each card it will actually
produce as many cards as i need in this
case it's gonna be 4.
so let's go ahead and do that i'm just
going to pass through some props into
this card
so i'm gonna pass through well first off
maybe let's just map
uh so
let's get our
burgers
map
i'm going to map for each burger and i'm
just going to get that
and
card and i'm going to pass through
the
burger
data
okay
so this is looking
good as always we should probably have a
key with this uh let's just see how this
is looking so there we go we've created
four cards as we have four
burgers
let's actually add the key prop as well
so i can
as the key just use the burger id as we
do have one so let's go ahead and do
that
okay
so we are creating the burgers let's
maybe give each burger some padding as
well so
margin even margin
pixels
just so it's a bit more space out and on
the card itself we're passing through
the burger so i'm going to destructure
the burger like so
otherwise we'd have to get the props so
i'm just destructuring the burger and
then let's make this maybe a little bit
bigger
i'm going to so in here
just grab that
add each of these so let's give them an
h2 tag let's pass through the
burgers
name
see what that looks like
so there you go you will see the burger
name is being shown just right here
what else can we pass through we can
pass through the
burger description
maybe let's make this a p
tag so there we go and then we can also
pass through as much information as we
wish so maybe let's put in another p tag
and call this burger
what did we have
location
and then burger location
address
okay
burger location
web i think that was one of them or was
it just website
it's a website
you can always check what it was go in
here i've got the description i've got
the name description we've got visited
we have location it's web okay address
web zip code probably don't really want
the zip code so i'm just going to keep
it as
web
okay so there we go and then we could
also hide it if we've uh been there or
you know which would mean we would only
see the ones we haven't but that is
completely up to you
okay
in fact i'm going to do this so if
burger
visited
is true
then we want to return back
um
i don't know what we can return back
just sort of freestyling here
uh a div that has the class name
visited
otherwise
we could just go if it's not visited
there's probably neater ways to do this
i am just freestyling here at the moment
as i've said
we can do
not visit it and it will show based uh i
will show this div if we visited it and
this one if we haven't visited it so
then i can go
visited and just style it up and if it's
visited i can just give it a green
or red actually let's make it red height
30 pixels
width
30 pixels
border
radius 15 pixels
background color
red because we don't want to see it and
if it's not visited we'll give it a
green
okay and let's make this
green
okay so there we go we know that this
means we visited and the green means we
have not visited these ones yet you can
replace this with icons i just wanted to
show you one way of doing that
wonderful
um okay so this is how you would get
data using the document api
and also using the document type
okay i'm just going to start this up a
tiny little bit before moving on
padding let's give this 30
pixels
let's make all the font white
font color
white
of course please feel free to uh you
know
take this project really improve on it
go crazy on the styling because that
part my friends is up
to
you this is not a styling
course
uh whoops cannot okay so we just have to
what is happening here
just going to comment that out for now
okay so it's not picking stuff up in
here
this is because sometimes the burger
data might not come back fast enough so
i'm just gonna put
uh
that right here okay good
okay
so it might not read it first time so
the first time this renders the burger
data might not exist which is why we put
this question mark here and when it
re-renders then it will show these cuts
okay great
so this is looking a lot better
great and then i'm just going to
override the font if there's an h1 tag
and give it the
font
color
black
cool
and let's just go back here
that back
wonderful and one last thing we do and
that is center everything so
on the body itself i'm going to do
display
flex
justify content
center
and text
and line
center
great
so wonderful i hope you've learned a lot
once again this code will be available
to you in the description if you're
watching this in the future some of
these packages might have changed just
make sure to use the same packages for
this
project
wonderful
thanks for watching and on to the next
project
in this project we're going to learn how
to use the graphql api in order to build
out a hotel app okay so once again i'm
going to start completely from scratch
in order to build out our react app
first things first i'm going to create a
new database so hopefully you are
familiar with these steps already if you
have been following with this tutorial
so what should we call our database this
time let's go ahead and call it whatever
we wish so i'm just going to call it
project work again
just like so and let's call our key
space name
hotels
the next thing i'm going to do is just
select where i am at the moment so i'm
gonna go ahead and let's pick europe
and west europe and just create a
database okay
so there we go there is our database it
is currently being created you will see
the status as pending and we're just
going to essentially wait until that is
active in order to start working with it
and there we go so let's go ahead and
click into here
and then here we will see our key space
now the first thing we're going to do is
just head over to the connect tab in
order to start working with our graphql
api
we're going to be using this
documentation right here to help us
so the first thing that we need to do is
just create a new application token so
i'm just going to click here to do that
and once again i'm going to select the
role i want i'm going to choose admin
however there are many others with
different readability levels and i'm
just going to create a token
once again i'm just going to copy this
right here and keep it somewhere safe
now once we have done that i'm just
going to close that down and i'm going
to launch the graphql playground by
clicking right here
so there we have it there is our
playground and in order to communicate
with our playground we need to just put
the token we have just created in the
http headers just like so
so now we can communicate with our
database let's go ahead and create our
first
table
so i can use the docs to help me with
this so this is the mutation i'm going
to be using once again if you watch the
tutorials you will know that we have
queries and mutations to our disposal
queries will essentially find data for
us and mutations can create delete and
update data for us
so we need to create a table so i'm just
going to get rid of this
and this is a mutation
and the mutation that i want is create
table
now if we look under here you will see
that to create a table i need so the
bang indicates that this is necessary i
need a key space name so let's go ahead
and pass that through
key space name i'm going to put this on
a new line
and the key space name has to be a
string
so i know that my key space name is
called hotels okay because that is the
key space that we named it right here so
if i go back to my databases hotels is
the key space name
and then
the table
name this is something that i'm going to
assign right here i'm just going to call
it hotel data so i have just chosen to
assign this to the table name right
now
the other necessary thing that we need
is the partition keys as an array so
let's go ahead and add that partition
keys
as an array
and i want my partition key so if we
just click on here
i need to give it a name and a type
so i'm going to go ahead and do that i
need to give it a name
which is a string so i'm going to choose
to sort all my hotels by a id
and then i also need the type and the
type i want this to be is actually going
to be
basic
text as i don't want this to be an
integer i want the id to take letters
and numbers okay so that is one column
that we have made so far the partition
keys if i want to add more columns
however i could do so thanks to
values so once again values is an array
so i'm just going to my values
and if this is one column this is
actually the column we are going to
filter by and search by and all these
additional ones are going to come back
if we search for this column
so
let's add another column again we need
to have a name for this which is going
to be the hotel name and the type for
this i know that i want this to be text
and if we want to add more columns so at
the moment we have
one column a second column
i'm going to have three columns in here
so this is actually going to have the
rating so i'm going to call this
rating and i'm going to give this an
integer
value okay
so there we
go
so now if we run this mutation
great we have created our table
wonderful
so now that we have created our table
let's get to adding data into our table
so
all i'm going to do is navigate into my
key space so as you can see here data
stacks has actually generated the url
for me i need to go into the hotels so
i'm just going to go up here
and instead of graphql schema i'm just
going to go
forward hotels to make sure that i'm in
the correct key space okay so there we
go and now instead of creating a table
if i look at the docs they will be
changed
i need to insert hotel data so now this
is the mutation i need once again it's a
mutation as we are going to be inserting
data so let's get our mutation
and this time i need to use insert hotel
data
just like so and what do we need to put
in here in order for this to work
well
i need to put through a value okay and
that is necessary that it's got a bang
there so we have to do it
i'm going to give it a value
and this time i'm just going to give it
the id i'm going to make up an id
i'm also going to give it a name so the
name of the hotel let's say
abby's
hotel and a rating which is an integer
so i'm going to give it a 4 out of 5.
so let's just actually put this on
different lines just like so
and let's just return back
the value
of
name to check this has worked and click
run
so great we have just inserted some data
into our table
okay
uh let's go ahead and just insert some
more so i'm just going to change these
around a little bit this time i'm going
to call this
satori's
give it a rating of five
there we go that has worked let's go
make another id up
this time it's gonna go
motel
maze
give it a rating of three
and then
one more and this one is going to be
awesome
[Music]
hotel and give it a rating of 5.
great
so now we know we have just added four
hotels into our database but how can we
actually see this well for this
we need a query so to query this i would
simply i can go here and have a look if
i need the queries i need is hotel data
so i'm just going to write hotel data
like so and because we are not filtering
out by anything i can just get the
values
and then choose whichever values i want
to come back so i can get all of them i
can get the id the name and the rating
and just click that
or i can just get the name and id
so that would return back or i could
just get the name whatever you wish so
however you write that query is what
will return back
to you
i want everything so i'm just going to
do that
and there we go
so that is essentially the query that we
need in order to get all of our data
from our database and we also need this
cassandra token as the http header and
also this url as that is where
essentially our data
lives
so
let's go ahead and do it let's start up
our project now
so all i'm going to do is get my
webstorm up
and just create a new
project
once again this is going to be a react
project so i'm just going to use this
and i'm going to call this hotel app
just like so and using npx create react
app this should create a project for me
with all the react configuration ready
to go so i'm just going to click select
so
and there we go you will see my hotel
app project right here and all the
dependencies being installed ready for
me to use
of course you don't have to use webstorm
if you're using another code editor or
ide that is absolutely fine too
just make sure you get up to this point
where your project is installing all the
dependencies ready to go
and great we are ready to go
so the first thing that i'm going to do
is actually just delete anything we
don't need so here are all the files
that have been generated as well as the
package and all of its dependencies and
scripts
so in here i'm actually just going to
get rid of the logo as we are not going
to need this anymore
so just delete that
delete anyway i'm going to delete the
report with vitals and set up tests so
once again just delete that as we don't
need it anyway
and then i'm going to delete the app css
file as i want all my styling to be in
the index css file and just delete the
app test.js so just delete that like so
okay
so this is looking good just going to
minimize that
and delete this as we don't have anymore
i'm going to delete the semicolons as
i'm not a fan of semicolons
there we go and save that and then in
the app.js file i'm going to delete all
of this as we don't need it anymore and
once again get rid of these semicolons
and we don't need the logo as we don't
have it we don't have this file either
okay
so this is looking
good
now if we run this i'm just gonna click
this to run the start
script
you should see
the project
show up here we've got rid of all the
styling so you should just see a blank
slate like so and let's get up our
console log
wonderful
so now that we have that let's get to
making some requests so i'm just going
to minimize that for now
in the previous project we built a
little mini back end using express
however this time i'm just going to show
you a different approach and that is
using netlify serverless functions so to
do this let's get off our terminal and
let's install
at the netify command line interface so
we can use it so npm install
net lift fi
cli and i'm going to install it globally
okay so that is what the g is for that
is to install that globally and just let
that run
okay so i'm going to leave that to do
its thing
the next thing we're going to do is
actually create our first serverless
function
okay so when that is done i'm just going
to ask you
to
create a file
in the root of your project so make sure
it's in the root of your project on the
same level as the package.json i'm just
going to minimize that
new and the file is called net live by
tomo
okay and in here i'm just going to give
you some code to put in in order to
build
out these serverless functions so this
you can just copy these are some
commands that we're gonna have to put in
here in order to build them out
functions here is essentially the uh
whatever you call the directory you want
to store your functions in so let's go
ahead and create that i'm going to
create that on the same
level so just make sure that's in the
root of your project and call the
directory functions just like you did
here okay so that is where we're going
to store our functions our serverless
functions
and then we just need
one more
command
okay
so there we go make sure to write this
exactly as i have written it in a
netlife file in the root of your project
great
so now that we have done that i'm going
to create my first function so making
sure you are in the functions directory
create a new javascript file and call it
whatever you want your function name to
be so i'm going to call this
get hotels
and this is a javascript file so that
will add the js extension
now with any serverless function
netlifeservice function this is the
syntax that you need
so let's go ahead and write it i'm going
to have to write export handler
and this is an async function
maybe let's make this a little bit
bigger
i'm gonna pass through an event
and then we are going to have to
essentially fetch some data so just like
we did before so we're gonna
import another directory so we're gonna
get
node fetch
i'm just going to install it right now
api
node
fetch
and let that install
okay so while that is installing let's
go ahead and use it in this file const
fetch equals require
node
fetch
like that
now
as we know with fetch we need to pass
through two things and that is a url and
options that will have our http header
along with the authorization token so
let's go ahead and do that
so once again let's write the url and we
know that the url so let's go back to
here
is this right here and this is where
we're going to make the request to
so i'm just going to paste that in here
like so and then let's also get our
options so
const
options
say this is const url
and the options are going to have
a method which is a get
request
and the headers okay the headers which
will consist of the content
type
content type and the x
cassandra
token
okay
so there we go i'm just going to make
this the same as we see here x cassandra
token and i'm just going to grab
that so the whole thing
and just put it in
here
just like
so
just going to make it
single quotes
great so we have our options and then we
also have our url i'm just going to
format this a little bit better so url
options and we're gonna use fetch
however this time we're actually gonna
save uh whatever comes back from fetch
so we know this comes back with the
promise const response so whatever that
returns back we're going to save as
response this time
and this is not all we actually need to
do
and because this time we actually have a
query to pass through okay so we do have
a query to pass through and that query
is i'm just going to save it up here
so i'm going to save it as const query
and i'm just going to use backsticks for
this
and i'm going to paste in my query so
let's go in here this is essentially the
query i want to make
so i'm just going to paste that in here
like so
and maybe format it a little bit better
we need to pass that query through in
with the
options
okay so this is no longer a get request
as we are posting we are sending this
query so make sure to change this to a
post
method
and let's get to
passing through the query into the body
so i'm going to pass through the query
but i need to pass it through jason
stringify
and then just pass through the query
like so
okay
great
so that is looking good we are now
passing through the query in with our
options so along with the cassandra
token the method and then we are putting
that into the fetch
that we imported from node fetch
great
now we're going to use try and catch in
order to do this
so this is the syntax for try and cat
we've got try and i'm going to catch any
errors so e4 errors
okay
and to try do this
we actually have to make sure this is
all in the export
handler so let's just grab that and make
sure that it is here
we are going to
well essentially we're getting the
response i'm going to call this response
body
so we could use this but we also need
the json from it and this returns a
promise so i'm gonna have to use oh wait
in front of it just like so
okay
and then if that comes back then we're
just gonna return a status code of 200
because that has worked and then we are
going to show in the browser
the response so i'm going to use json
string 5 to work i'm going to show the
response body in the browser and if it
doesn't work but we catch the errors and
we're just going to console.log the
errors
okay we can also of course return a
status code too so i'm going to do
return status code 500 and i'm just
going to show the error in the actual
browser too so let's use json string phi
and pass through if error
okay so this is looking good before we
clean this up let's just check that it
works
so to do this i'm just gonna go in here
and i need to run the command netlify
netlify
dev
and let us do its magic
okay
so there we go localhost 888.
let's inspect the page
and now if if we want to get
that
data if we want to run this function
essentially i need to go into functions
and get hotels
okay
oops make sure this is an s
so i'm going to go forward slash
dot net
life i
forward slash functions as that is the
directory that we created and then get
the test
and
wonderful so now we are getting all of
our
data and
so it is saying something's already
running on port 3000. i thought i did
shut this down but i didn't cancel
okay so we need to stop that running
just make sure that's
stopped okay
essentially what is happening here is
that localhost 888 is now our front end
okay so we don't want anything running
on localhost 3000 because we want
everything to be running on here okay so
that's what we want and to
and essentially our front end and our
back end are now on this url so here we
go to get our data and here is our
front end
great
so i hope that makes sense
once again just make sure
that netlify dev is running in order to
get that to work
wonderful so
once again i'm just going to show you
the package json these are the packages
that i am using if yours have changed or
if you're watching it's in the future
then please use these for the tutorial
in order to get this code here to work
okay so there we go those other packages
that you need along with their
versions
wonderful
now that we have our data let's get to
cleaning this up a bit so just like we
did before i'm going to create a new
file
a dot env file in which we're going to
store all our secrets so once again i'm
just going to put the end point in here
and i'm also going to put in my astra
token
so just like that and then from here i'm
just going to get this url
to get the whole thing
and put it in here and i'm also going to
get my
token
okay
so there we go
just like so it doesn't need to be a
string
we can just save it like that
okay and now this means i can use
process env
in order to get my astra token
and i can also
use it to get the url but now it's
hidden okay so now it's a bunch safer
end
point
great
and we have to actually inject these
variables otherwise this won't work so i
just inject the variables by running
netlifedev again
so just like sir okay and you will see
injected endpoint uninjected
astra token okay
so there we go
let's try that again only absolute urls
endpoint
and point
end point uh i miss spelt and point
okay so once again i need to re-inject
the token so notify dev
and wait for that too
we run
and wonderful
so now we have a url that will get back
our data as long as the back end is
running let's get to using it in the
front end
so i'm done with this for now let's have
a look if this needs any cleaning up so
here we have all the code that is
necessary this will be available to you
below so please make sure to use it you
don't actually need to pass through an
event for this this is looking
good okay so there is all my code
great now let's move on to the front end
so here is my front end
as you can see here once again i'm gonna
have to
essentially fetch the data so i'm just
gonna do fetch data just like we did
before we're gonna make this an async
function
okay let's change this to a function
expression just because i prefer working
in this way
and now let's actually fetch the data
so now this time i am going to actually
use
fetch so
the fetch api i'm going to await it as
it's going to come back with a promise
and i'm just going to fetch
this url right here so i'm going to copy
that and paste it however we don't need
all of this i can simply put forward
slash netlify functions get hotel so
that is essentially the same thing
okay so we're getting the data from
there and then let's go ahead and save
it as something so i'm going to save it
as just the response for now const
response
great so that's the line we need to
write now once we
have whatever comes back from us so the
response
um
we need to get us json
however this also returns a promise so
we need to use a weight and let's save
this as response
body
this time and we're going to have to
actually save this into state so i'm
just going to import
use state and also use effect as we're
going to need it later
from
react
okay awesome so we've got the response
body let's actually save it to the state
of the app
so let's use what should we have hotels
set
hotels
and then use
state i'm going to start off with the
state being
no
okay so all this means is that at the
moment hotels is null and i can use set
hotels to make hotels whatever i wish
but at the moment we're starting out
with hotels being not so this gets
passed on to that and i can use this to
also change that so i'm going to use set
hotels to change hotels to the response
body
wonderful
i think let's check out if this has
worked
so i'm gonna now use use effect
and then a callback function if you
don't know about use effect i would
suggest uh doing some research on these
hooks at the moment so use effect just
like so i'm going to fetch the data okay
and then i'm just going to put up like
an empty array so it doesn't keep
fetching that data over and over again
so i'm going to call that and now let's
console.log hotels to see if this has
worked and to see what's being returned
back to us
so now let's go back here and just go to
the front end
and
there we go
we are getting the response body data
data hotel data so data hotel data
values is what we need and that is an
array so i'm just going to go back here
and go response body data hotel
data
values
okay in order for that to bring back
just the
array and there we go we have an array
of four
wonderful
let's carry on
so now that we have that and we have
checked that that has worked there's the
whole code in its entirety please feel
free to stop here and make a note of it
or just catch up press pause and if you
caught up let's carry on
so just like we did before i'm actually
just going to map out all the hotels i'm
not going to create a card component
this time as you know how to do that so
i'm just going to grab the hotels if
they exist and i'm going to map so dot
map
and for each
hotel
well
i want to
return a div
let's give it the class name
of
hotel
and then in here let's put an h1 tag
that has the hotel
name
a p tag
that has the
hotel
what were the other ones hotel name then
we have a hotel
rating
so let's see how that looks
and
there we go we get all four of our
hotels with a little rating too
now let's get to starting this up a
little bit
so here is my app i'm just going to get
my css file
let's put everything in the body as
justify content
center of course we need to use display
flex to initialize this
and align
text
text line apologies text
align
center
okay
so that is looking good and anything
with a class of hotel
i'm going to make sure that the
background color
is
salmon
and border
radius
is 50
okay so maybe that's a bit too much
border radius we can of course change it
let's maybe make it just 10
or whatever really that you wish
it is up to
here
great so of course uh please again feel
free to go wild on the styling i don't
want to go too crazy on the styling this
is not what this is about this is a
tutorial to show you how to get data
into a project okay so i'm just going to
put my hotels here and maybe let's make
this in each
to
tag like so
great and maybe let's give it some
padding
uh from the top let's give it 10 pixels
and from each side i'm going to go 50
pixels should make it look really
long
okay and then also
margin
five pixels
great
okay so hopefully you've learned a lot
in how to get the data this time using
graphql and the graphql api if you want
to learn more about how to make more
advanced requests so in making the
functions including stuff like
pagination i do suggest watching my
netflix clone in which we use graphql to
do this okay so that is an option for
you please try go ahead and watch that
if you wish it is reviewed by an actual
netflix engineer too once again the code
for this project will be available in
the description below
and that's it so to recap during this
video course we have learned what is
nosql
sql versus nosql and why you can't
compare them types of nosql databases so
document databases key value databases
wide column stores or tabular databases
graph databases and talks about the
multi-modal databases we also talked
about how to get data into projects with
two real life examples and also how to
look at the document api and graphql api
as we did this so an action pack course
really and if you're looking for ideas
on where to go next to really solidify
your knowledge i would recommend using
the document api and sdk to build your
own takedown app with me here or using
the gracua api to build a netflix clone
here or even learn how to federate data
from two database types with my graphql
federation crypto app right here
thanks so much for watching and i will
see you again soon